if you're like us you've often shipped
two characters from different worlds so
would have characters from the Disney
verse got together with characters from
the Nickelodeon world here's our list of
10 Disney and Nickelodeon crossover
couples were totally shipping watch
until the end for a ship that might very
well blow your mind
Henri danger and Andy Mack when you
think about it it just makes sense
Andy is super-smart creative and
resourceful she can make bracelets out
of almost anything
Henri is a very expressive person he has
a lot of ambition charm and a way with
the ladies
he would definitely sweep Andy off her
feet if they were ever to meet and he
can be kind of socially awkward
especially when she has a crush on
someone
combine that with Henry's natural goofy
cheesy side and that would make for a
downright adorable couple
both andy and henry are naive they don't
like it when people keep important
secrets from them so they would probably
have a pretty open and honest
relationship henry is courageous and
clever which goes perfectly with Andy's
naturally curious inquisitive style even
though he can be kind too full of
himself
Henry really cares about his friends and
family and he has saved a lot of lives
this makes him excellent boyfriend
material for Andy Andy is very
trustworthy so Henry will be able to
tell her anything he isn't very good at
hiding his real feelings anyway if he
had a crush on Andy she would probably
know it immediately
it's no wonder fans are shipping these
to Nia and Nicki Nia from the Disney
Show Ravens home has a lot to offer
she's smart logical good at planning
ahead and has an eye for detail Nikki
from Nickelodeon's Nicky Ricky Dicky and
Dawn is the quietest and most well
mannered quad among his siblings he
loves to cook so you know he can whip up
a nice romantic picnic for Nia because
he's a quadruplet he has learned to go
with the flow but he has shown that he
can be very mischievous if he has the
opportunity Nia would be a good balance
for Nikki she has a twin brother so she
can relate to Nikki's experience better
than most granted he has three siblings
whereas Nia only has one
however Nikki can certainly relate to
Nia having a twin while Nia's brother
Booker and her mom Raven have psychic
abilities
Nia relies on logic rather than her gut
feelings this could be a good thing for
Nikki she can remind him to think before
he acts which can help keep him to stay
out of trouble
Nia tries to impress
others by acting more mature than she
actually is but with Nikki she would
probably be comfortable being herself
these two would be a pretty cute couple
don't you think Dicky and Frankie we all
know Frankie from the Disney Show Buzard
Park she loves to create songs and funny
videos through the Google studio she can
be very pragmatic and sometimes even a
bit cynical but she can be very daring
and bold image is important to Frankie
just like image is important to Dickie
Dickie is a third born of the
quadruplets Nicky Ricky Dicky and Dawn
he considers himself to be a pretty cool
and chill guy he's known as the ladies
man of the group he's easygoing and a
bit dim-witted but what he is lacking in
common sense he makes up for with charm
and personality he gets himself in
trouble a lot but always seems to be
able to handle whatever comes his way
Frankie is a creative girl with a lot to
offer it would be interesting to see
Dicky and Frankie together maybe Frankie
would help Dicky get in touch with his
creative side he could even help her
with her videos she is a good friend and
let's face it she's downright hilarious
she could give Dickie something to care
about besides just his good looks
these two would make a very interesting
match KC Cooper and max thunderman you
know that saying opposites attract well
for this particular crossover couple
that statement couldn't be any more
accurate KC Cooper from Disney's KC
Undercover is smart
wee and very mature for her age she's a
black belt in martial arts she's amazing
at math and loves to play basketball max
thunderman from the Nickelodeon show the
thundermans may have a completely
different background and different
abilities but these two actually have a
lot in common
max grew up in a family of superheroes
and Casey grew up in a family of spies
they both have to deal with the pressure
of these secretive worlds and they must
prove themselves in order to follow the
footsteps of their family members
Casey prefers to study over playing
around max is very smart and has
invented a lot of gadgets and potions in
his villain lair but where Casey works
hard max has been known to be a bit of a
slacker yet he always seems to be one
step ahead of everyone else still Casey
would be good for max she would be able
to ground him and push him to live up to
his full potential as a superhero Dora
and Kim whether they're in a romantic
relationship or part of a friendly duo
we think live-action Dora the Explorer
and a live-action Kim Possible would
make a fabulous team both of them have a
flair for adventure they aren't afraid
of action
high-stakes scenarios and they both have
upbeat attitudes
Dora loves the outdoors and exploring
far-off lands while Kim always goes for
her next mission take sir Doran can both
seem to have trouble fitting into high
school life though outdoor seems to be a
lot more clumsy and sort of a don't look
before you leap kind of gal Kim
carefully plans her strategy and
implements skilful tactics to execute
her plan of action
a perfect example is the one where Dora
gets her backpack stuck in the door of
the school bus whereas Kim uses her
grappling hook to catch up with the bus
despite their differences we could see
these two teaming up for a jungle
expedition Dora can bring Diego and Kim
can bring Ron stoppable anyone else
think that they should make a movie that
brings these two together we'd pay to
see that
dower and Kim are two brave girls with
great senses of humor and a love for
excitement it's a good combo Keira and
Jay Jay from Disney's descendants is the
son of the villain Jafar from Aladdin he
is sneaky handsome and very sure of
himself he's on the fencing team at our
Don Pop and he knows how to use a sword
Kira from Nickelodeon's Knight squad was
born as a princess in Astoria but she
wants to be more than just a princess
she wants to become a knight she can
fight for her kingdom she has to rebel
against her dad to go to night school
and Jay can totally relate to wanting to
break the mold he did the same thing
with his dad when he went to auradon and
decided to renounce his villain
background Kira knows something about
trickery just like Jay she had to use
her magic ring to transform into Kira so
no one would know that she's a princess
Jay is very playful and loves to kid
around with his friends he will surely
be able to put a smile on Kira's face
they both know something about living in
a kingdom that is ruled by kings and
queens very good at fighting and they
both know what it's like to venture out
from their parents shadows we think that
makes them very compatible now and art
if you think these two rebels would make
a good match we agree 100% now from
Disney's descendants is the daughter of
Maleficent she gets an opportunity to
get off the Isle of the Lost for all the
villains are exiled so she can go to
school at our dime prep but her mother
has other plans for her mal ultimately
decided to rebel against her mother and
her evil plans so she can become good
arc from Nickelodeon's knight squad was
born into a family with no royal ties or
magic abilities though
his land was taken over by Rikers army
he vowed to save his people by becoming
a knight he had to rebel against the
norm in order to get into night school
because he is not from the noble dragon
blood heritage so he adopts a secret
identity in order to get into school we
think mouths dragon background would be
very attractive to Ark and from mouths
time as the blond-haired princess in
descendants - she can totally relate to
the whole secret identity thing but how
would they be if they were together Ark
is very funny nice and smart and mal is
very resourceful caring and strong both
of them can be pretty mischievous so we
think that they would have a ton of fun
together star butterfly and Timmy Turner
star butterfly is an intergalactic
princess and Disney's star versus the
forces of evil on her birthday her mom
gives her a royal magic wand which she
was definitely not responsible enough to
handle she winds up creating so much
chaos and destruction her parents send
her away to earth there she is learning
how to use her magic safely Timmy Turner
is just your average kid that no one
understands he is neglected by his
parents so he winds up with two magical
fairy godparents Cosmo and Wanda Timmy
is kind of selfish sometimes and very
arrogant he makes a lot of irresponsible
wishes which is very godmothers must
grant
while both star and Timmy have the
potential to cause a lot of chaos around
them they're very smart
they're both optimistic and love to have
fun just imagine the shenanigans these
two we get into if they were together
there's no telling what might happen
Timmy would have to get over his crush
on Trixie first though we know that star
will want all of Timmy's attention these
two would probably have some very epic
lovers quarrels they both can be pretty
stubborn but they would have wild
adventures to Phoebe and Carlos Phoebe
Thunderman from Nicks the thundermans is
an awesome superhero with powers that
include telekinesis heat breath and
breeze breath she goes by the title
Thunder girl her family tree is gushing
with super abilities Carlos from
Disney's descendants comes from a family
of evil villains but since Phoebe's
brother max was a villain she can
totally relate to having an evil streak
in her family and that's not all Phoebe
and Carlos have in common
she loves math and is highly intelligent
Carlos is a tech whiz they would
probably have a lot of nerdy stuff to
talk about Phoebe is usually very
friendly unless you see her with her
twin brother Matt
Carlos can also be friendly unless use
amongst the other villains on the aisle
he had to teach Ben how to fit in with
the villains on the aisle
Phoebe tries to live a regular life she
wants to have a social life after being
severely bullied when he was on the Isle
it's important to Carlos to develop real
relationships we think it would be fun
for Carlos to see you at Phoebe is
capable of and Carlos could make Phoebe
very happy if she let him Don and Dona
Don Harper from Nickelodeon's Nicky
Ricky Dicky and Dawn is the oldest of
her siblings five four seconds she is
charming energetic and always in charge
Jonah is the popular athletic guy from
Disney's Andy Mac he is also energetic
and playful making for an ideal match
with Don Jonah is a loyal friend to Andy
he is good at keeping secrets
as Andy well knows but sometimes he can
let his emotions get the best of him
this could be a problem with Don's
tendency to be selfish and petty at
times while Jonah is a loyal friends he
can be indecisive when it comes to love
that would definitely frustrate time but
if they could get past all of that they
would probably have a blast together
they both really like sports
we're pretty sure Don can outrun Jonah
in a race if she wanted to Don and Donna
have many things in common but they also
have their differences so would it be a
match made in heaven or with this
romance fizzle out before it even got
off the ground what do you think are you
shipping a favorite Disney Nickelodeon
crossover couple if so tell us all about
your OTP in the comments below thanks
for watching the things if you liked
this video be sure to give it a big
thumbs up and don't forget to hit that
subscribe button for more videos like
this one see you next time
[Music]